okay today I'd like to talk to you about
some techniques that you can add to
basic search to enable your systems to
make more intelligent decisions and save
computation time last time we introduced
basic search and the basic idea of how
to encode search so that our system can
use search when encountering an unknown
territory or state space and today we're
going to review some things you can do
in terms of using the information that
you know and also using estimations of
the information that you would like to
know to improve your chances of
discovering the path that you're
interested in the fastest the first
thing that we can do in order to improve
our search is use dynamic programming
dynamic programming refers to the idea
that once you've done a computation for
a particular kind of problem you can
save that computation and use it later
as opposed to having to engage in that
computation a second time the way this
manifests and search is that once you've
visited a particular state you don't
have to visit that state again because
the way your agenda set up you found the
fastest way to that particular state as
far as you're concerned so the general
idea is that once you visit a particular
state you don't have to visit it again
if you're building a normal search tree
it can be difficult to keep track of
where you've been especially you're
doing something like a first search to
get around this and to enable dynamic
programming the easiest thing to do is
just keep a list of the states that you
visited as a consequence of this
particular run of search I'm going to
demonstrate dynamic programming by
running depth-first search on our state
transition diagram from last time the
first two steps are the same except for
the fact that we're going to keep track
of the fact that we visited both a B and
C as a consequence of the first two
iterations of search
if I'm running depth-first search my
agenda acts as a stack which means I'm
going to take the partial paths that I
added most recently to the agenda pop it
off and expand the last node in the
partial path when I expand see I'm going
to visit B and D however B is already in
my list of states that I visited because
it's already in one of the partial paths
in my agenda so I'm not going to visit B
again instead I'm only going to add one
new partial pass to my agenda a CD I'm
also going to add D to my list of
visited States if I run another
iteration of depth-first search I find
my goal
for completeness he's added to the list
of visited States this took even fewer
iterations than the original depth-first
search
we didn't waste time expanding different
nodes we also use less space in the
general sense the concept of dynamic
programming is great to use whenever you
can and in search it can save you a lot
of time and energy another way we can
intelligently improve our search
technique is by making considerations
for costs that we know that are
associated with particular transitions
in this state transition diagram I've
indicated some costs associated the
transitions between particular States if
we know the costs associated with
transitions then we can use accumulation
of the weights accumulated through
traversing a particular partial path to
prioritize which paths we're going to
explore first in an effort to reduce the
amount of cost associated with our final
actions in order to that we can sort the
agent we can keep track of the value
associated with that cumulation and sort
the agenda at every iteration based on
that cost if we're using dynamic
programming while making considerations
for both costs and heuristics and also
when we're running the goal test when
making considerations for costs and
heuristics we're actually going to make
our considerations when we expand the
node as opposed to when we visit the
node this difference is very important
because it provides us with the most
optimal solution if it's possible for us
to visit the gold node but it's a
hundred cost units away it may be worth
our while to search for alternatives
that provide a much shorter path to the
gold node that's why we switch from
considering when we visit to considering
when we expand let's look at uniform
cost search run with dynamic programming
now my first step I expand a and add two
partial paths to my queue I'm also going
to keep track of the cumulative cost
associated with that partial path when I
expand a I add any of the agenda note
that I haven't talked about stacks or
queues or death first or breadth-first
or anything we're working with a
priority queue and what that means is
that things with a higher priority float
to the top or things with the lowest
cost associated with them we're going to
consider first this means that I'm going
to expand B in the partial path a B
first I'll add it to my list when I
expand B B is two child nodes D and C a
B C has partial path cost three
associated with it and a B D has partial
path cost 11 associated with it that
means when I reprioritize my queue I'm
going to end up sorting everything such
that AC comes first
ABC comes second
and a beedi comes third previously with
our strategy for dynamic programming C
would not have been added to this
partial path because we've already
visited it with path AC at this step
we're going to expand the path AC add C
to the list and any other time that we
end up visiting C we will not add it to
our paths if I expand see I have a
transition to B which is already in my
list and a transition to D that has cost
seven
ABC is gonna float to the top of my
priority queue ACB is not going to be
considered because B is already part of
my list and a BD is going to remain with
cost eleven
at this point you might say but Kendra
why am i considering partial path ABC
when C is in my list for C should be in
my list excuse me
as a consequence of expanding the
partial path AC even though we expanded
the partial path AC if we have not made
any considerations to weed out our list
at every iteration this is still going
to float to the top and we're still
going to have to deal with it even
though we've already expanded C since
we've already expanded C we're going to
ignore this partial path and just move a
CD 7 and a BD 11 up to the front
D is not in our expanded list when we
expand D we have one child node E
because we're working with costs and
heuristics we do not have out we do not
actually evaluate the goal test when we
visit a node we evaluate it when we
expand a node so I am going to add a CDE
to my agenda it's going to have cost 8
and a BD 11 still gonna hang out here at
the back of the pirate priority queue at
this point I get to expand II I skipped
adding D to the expanded list when I
expanded it from a CD to a CDE at this
point I'm going to expand E and the
first thing I'm going to do is test and
see whether or not it passes the goal
test at that point I stop search
returned that I successfully completed
the search and that my partial path is
going to be AC de
that covers uniform cost search at this
point you might say Kendra this is
bearing a lot of similarity to things
like maps and I would be really liked to
be able to use my knowledge of things
like the Euclidean distance in order to
make more intelligent even more
intelligent decisions about where it is
that I go with myself and I would say
yes you should be able to in fact people
do in fact people do all the time they
they say well something's you know this
far away is the crow flies so I know
that if I've gone further than that at
any point then I've wasted some amount
of time but it represents a good under
estimate of the distance that I'm going
to cover this is the basic concept of
heuristics if you're attempting to find
a goal and you have an estimate for the
remaining cost but you know it's not
exactly right you can still use that
information to attempt to save you an
amount of computation or amount to
search in particular you probably
shouldn't be using heuristic if you know
it's perfect because if you know that
heuristic is perfect then you should be
using the heuristic to solve your
problems instead of doing search in the
first place or if if the heuristic
already tells you how long it's going to
take to find something then it probably
also has the path that represents how
long or that represents that amount of
cost when you if you want to use in a
heuristic effectively you have to make
sure that your heuristic represents a
non strict under estimate of the amount
of cost that is left over and what do I
mean by that I mean that if you have a
heuristic and it's you're using it as a
thing to tell you whether or not you're
wasting your time if your career stick
represents information that is bogus
or says this particular path has more
cost associated with it than it actually
does then it will lead you astray or you
don't want to use a heuristic that will
prevent you from using a path that
actually costs less than the heuristic
advertises this is what's known as an
admissible heuristic an admissible
heuristic always underestimates if it
makes an error in estimation about your
total distance to the goal all right so
at this point I've covered dynamic
programming I've covered costs of cover
to your sticks and it turns out that you
can use all of these techniques at the
same time when you use both costs and
heuristics in combination while
evaluating your priority queue that's
known as an a-star search and you'll see
a decent amount of literature on a star
this covers all of the intelligent
improvements to basic search that I will
talk about in this course we hoped you
enjoyed 601